CABLE WS.DES S IKF CNN BOSS KEH
COME NEXT SO  ONG
FROM INSIDE THIS VER
ORGANIZATION.
SINCRN
THE DOMINANM  IS D THIS HAPTHI
AND HE WAS GONE THE NEXT, SO DI
THEM, DEND.AD EVER WORKE WALARDO
HE SHIS STAF HEAT.FROM CORPORA E
HEADLINEY AND EVERY  K I LIKE HA
HIS SOLUTION TO M, THE THAT HET
ERS DON'AL
BREATHE, LIVE , BU
DLIN
WHSTD
S
HAS NEWS IN HIS VEINS ANTLY  KN
STEE SURE HEEXS
IT NEW
SO LETO ANSW THE
ESS OF
PART OITH.OR
PR
WEDNESDA AS
PART THAT WAS CIATED,
E BACKDROP T
LOMEGA MR.MEDIA ARE BEUN
OFF RIGHT NO
THE N OF A NEWERY.
THE CURRENT CEOF DISCOVE NEWPA ,
ASSUMING THEOVSHNGT
COMES TO THE GOVERNMEN
TORY REV BIGOUOF STRESS FOR THEM
T O GO DO THE MANAGEMENT RIGHT
ANYTHING IS GOING TO GEES GOIN
TOE EFFECT
JEFF Z, AS THEKGROUN
THESE HEADLINES SAY, HSIGNEDOVE
STS CUOMO.T'
CUOMO'S SEONER
RELA
ONT.
THINK BACK O
SCANDAL SURROUNDING NEYO
CHRIS ANACHES
FOR MONTHSRES
WHETCNTHGH
BY KPI CUOMOR
THNN.
EVENALLY ZUCHRHE NPAS  CUOMOCAL.
RE THECOLI
CUSNILTY JUST LIKE
SEE IT H IAY CUOMO'S
DOSO I'MG .ALLIES REJEC VIEW,EYD
EITHER WAY ZUCKEDI
HAT USE OF'S FTHE ZUN NT
T THERE'S CE  WEYETHER?
BETWEEN WONDG AN AND I
CHANNELINGS OF MANY  IHIS IS THF
COD
BOWS . AT
FRNDREW DO T
ZU
I SHAKESPEARIAN.S BOSS WARNEA H
T IT AT  S GUESS I KAL
R FOR THEY SAID HEREHED  T RIO H
GS US BACKON INSIDE Y?EEK, BUT .
BRI,
SHE SA IE E N'T FIT THE CRIME. N
THSIDE CNN, BUER
NELE HBR
RULES ALL THE TIME.BEYOND THAS
WOIMING IS,  W NEEDSDE
TO GROY , ANCOCA
SOR  ACONTINUES WITHOUT S E S Y,
Y AT WARNE
ANGRY ATUO AND
NO HAS ADY RELIABLNS
THERS OFERTEAM
OVAEL BAANNOW WHAT T THEY'REG I.
KEEPINN G
THIS DEAL CLOSES, PROBABLY
MSC BOSS,EW
CNN.S THAT
DISCOVERY S THISFOR CNN.